[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's a grown man and his football team
still makes him cry he's darius rucker
the country music star
and currently headlining shows across
the country had an opportunity to see
him uh a week or so yeah a week ago in
uh connecticut latest single my
masterpiece climbing up the charts
how are you this morning darius
i'm good dan how are you doing i'm doing
okay uh do you bet on college football
yes
do you bet well on college football i
don't bet well on anything no i'm awful
but i still do it do you what's your uh
your worst beat your bad beat
oh i've gotten some bad beats probably
the worst beat i ever got was uh
it was an nba game and uh you know how
at the end of nba game like at the end
when you're getting really beat down you
know you dribble the ball out nobody
scores well i had the under and it was
one point under and some rookie was in
the game
for the knicks and the rookie was in the
game and he was 12 seconds left they're
down 20. and he grabs the rebound and
races down the court and lays it up
to go over and i'm
it was the worst bet it was the worst
beat i ever had we always talk about the
bad beats but do you have because we do
get those wins where you're like and oh
by the way and somebody kicks a field
goal or whatever it might be
because i i had a bad beat i don't
remember the ones that i actually did
well on but there was one where chester
markle
was the field goal kicker for the
packers
all he has to do is kick a field goal
against the bears and i cover
the bears block the field goal it goes
back to chester markle and he runs it in
for a touchdown
and i and i i lose
on that that's a bad beat right there
that is a bad b that's one of the
reasons why among the many reasons i
don't i don't gamble anymore
i can't do it makes sense didn't work
for me i still i still do it and i still
you know i just i feel like guess i
gotta give somebody some money because i
just love to do it but do you ever bet
against your your favorite team the
dolphins
never i've never been against the
dolphins or the gamecocks in my life and
i don't bet on a leader though oh okay i
was gonna say should you bet against
them if exactly
if if i gave you a guarantee
you were going to win a bet
against
your south carolina game conchs or miami
but everybody was going to find out that
you bet against that team which which
team would you bet against south
carolina or miami oh good question if i
had to bet against one
i'd probably bet against the gamecocks
yeah you know probably just because uh
we don't cover a lot sometimes
how would you describe your setup
at south carolina home games
oh i have my tailgating setup is second
to none i have a great i got my little
fenced in area with my cock-a-boos and
and you know our artificial grass and we
my setup is is the best set up and for
tailgating in south carolina for sure i
didn't want to go into the game
i wanted to stay i wanted to stay in the
train car
yeah we had a blast yeah that's that's
where the party is
yeah
and and it the train car is big enough
to entertain and then there's an outdoor
area there as well i mean you know
i it's a i mean i'm letting the danettes
know they're not going to be invited but
if they ever win i like i could send you
pictures next time yeah i'd love to see
you come and send pictures to them and
they'll be okay yeah
uh
when's the first time you noticed the
dolphins like what happened where you
went that's my team now
i was five years old and the dolphins
were playing the cowboys in the super
bowl and my family all my whole family
was over to watch the game
and i remember being five years old and
going around and asking everybody who
they were rooting for
and everybody was rooting for the
cowboys i mean everybody and so i
decided that day that uh i was gonna
root for the dolphins
and i did in the super bowl and they
lost i remember you know being a little
kid probably shouldn't have still been
awake but they lost and i cried
and then the next year i started playing
pop water football and you know the
dolphins went undefeated so it was
really easy to be i'll be a fan and i've
been a fan ever since that was fine
and but do they still make you cry
no after that uh 1-15 season i stopped
crying
[Laughter]
that was it no more crying after that
season are you all in on tua
yeah uh yes
wait a minute
but if you could get to sean watson
i like desean
um
we don't know what we're gonna get with
the john you know but i think he's a
great player but uh
i'm with whatever floors whatever floors
wants to do of it are you singing the
national anthem anytime soon yes at the
home opener i am
also wait you're going to be in new york
on saturday
and then you're oh when did the dolphins
open up no they we all
they're on the world this weekend oh
that's right yeah
the next weekend how much do you
rehearse a national anthem
not at all i don't rehearse it but i
tell you one thing i do when i when i
when i'm about to do it i before i go on
i'm making sure i'm in the right key i'm
like the whole time i'm going oh say
because if you start that thing too high
you have a car lewis moment
and that would not be very good i don't
want to call this moment have you had
one of those moments
uh no because i always started low
enough
i i started low enough so i i really
haven't had one of those moments so i i
mean that's still my one of my favorite
things i've ever seen on television so
no i don't want one of those moments
what do you hear though when you're
doing the anthem
just me singing really you know that's
all i want like just hearing me sing and
try not to miss the notes and without
really trying not to forget the words
but but you don't hear that that echo
though in the stadium
you do
but like stadiums now have a monitor
most stadiums now have a monitor like i
did at yankee stadium years ago david
wells had me come out doing yankee
stadium they didn't have a monitor
and i usually do the answer with
probably about a minute 16
and that day i did it like three minutes
because i had to keep waiting for the
echo
it was awful it was awful the best
anthem ever was done by who
the worst one ever the best
the best ever uh
probably i i think it's a tie between
kate smith and i know uh the marvin gaye
one marvin gaye and whitney houston two
best ever
because whitney did it at the super bowl
in tampa right the marvin did it at the
nba all-star game and they were both
those are my two favorites
i remember watching the marvin gaye one
but i was there when when whitney
houston did that one in tampa and and
that was it was spectacular
it's the greatest the greatest rendition
i've ever heard of
it was amazing
you're doing the uh 9 11 show that's
going to be in new york city uh this
weekend coming up
yes i am okay yeah me and a bunch of
guys what what's happening with the the
911 uh this is a pier 17 this weekend
the anniversary of 9 11 this saturday
yeah i think it's a it's a good it's a
guitar pull a bunch of us going to sit
around and play some songs for uh
for for the folks it's really to
commemorate 9 11 it's but you know it's
that that day will always live
in our in the lexicon of america so you
know to be a part of that is just i
think it's really special they got the
lineup's incredible it's gonna be
awesome
you ever get intimidated with any you
said you'd love to perform with paul
mccartney but is there anybody where you
went
wow
i'm actually singing yeah when you when
you do a guitar pull with chris
stapleton and he's got to sing right
before you
that's awful
you know what i do this is how much of a
friend i am to darius i'll send him
chris stapleton songs just to let him
know
that guy can sing
[Laughter]
i tell him the story though about chris
stapleton who's one of the great
songwriters
but didn't you have a rule with chris
stapleton if he wrote you a song
oh we have a we have a
i have a rule with him when we write
together that he can't sing the demo
because uh
he's saying the demo the cut he's saying
the demo the comeback song and so we're
making the record and my producer's like
hey man i love this comeback song and
i'm like man i'm not really feeling that
one man you know i don't want to do it
he's like man so finally we're almost
done and and he goes man why don't you
want to do the comeback song i was like
have you heard the demons
[Laughter]
so yeah that's our rule he can't sing
the demo if we could rewrite himself did
you almost not become a singer
i mean what would you have done
i wanted to do what you do but you know
i'd probably be work i'd probably be
bartending playing at the windjammer on
friday night
wait you wanted to be a sportscaster
i went to school for that yeah broadcast
journalism no kidding yeah
did you put a a resume tape together do
you have goodness though dude i started
doing boobs i was 19. i didn't have a
resume tape for i mean once the hoodie
started this is all i was going to do oh
so then you were you didn't do a local
radio station or campus radio station no
it was i was just in school for it and
then hoodie started and i didn't you
know this is the only job i've had since
then is hooty gonna come back at any
time
uh you know we're doing that thing in
cancun which is going to be cool and uh
i'm sure we'll tour again sometime
probably no time soon but we'll tour
again
well you waited what 25 years to to do
it again didn't you or how many it was
15 years between
15. yeah which is crazy that's crazy
who were some of the people who went
backstage with you guys where where all
of a sudden you go oh my god that person
knows who we are
oh the rem guys that was when they were
doing like when mike bill started
hanging out and stuff that freaks us out
like to get us on to get him on stage
playing you know rockville or something
that that freaks um
it was this this last tour it was really
cool it was it was a bunch of stars came
backstage and everything we were
surprised you know we just we still
think we're just the luckiest dudes on
the planet but it's it's been really
cool that that tour was a lot of fun
well you basically started your career
just doing rem songs
yeah there was one point in our set
where we had like 10 oreos
10 out of how many songs 10 out of 27
do you have a cover song that you went
this didn't go well this isn't good oh
yeah the first song we ever stopped
playing was uh uh was uh
the sultan's a swing we played that once
and it didn't go well
didn't go well why why did you think
that you could channel the dire straits
um
we were young
and thought we could we couldn't it was
not very good no
do you know we had uh john hall on for
hall of notes
john oates uh of holland yeah so we had
him on last week and
and fritzy
sang
a duet with uh john owens
object that was really good
um but he didn't sing a whole note song
what do you think what uh what you're
saying a righteous brother song oh that
was that
love and feelings yeah you lost that
level
i know but it was a cover but you didn't
really do a whole i'd be like somebody
said hey let's do a duet with a hootie
in the blowfish song but we're we're
going to do a cover
we're going to do an rem song
but no that i'm with richie now and that
that that song yeah that's the song i
love their version of that song
i'm with you fred thank you because
that's because john sung a lot in that
particular i know i know it wasn't their
original one but that's one of the only
whole no songs i could think of where
he's like the main singer of that song
frenchy give valeris just a little bit
of what you uh gave to
my friends wonder why i call you all the
time what can i say
i don't feel the need to give such
secrets away
because you're kissed no no
but
you don't want somebody's reaction to be
laughing
no
especially that laughs yeah yeah
yeah um true yeah
that sounded really good fritzy thank
you that he no he did no it's it didn't
no
it did no it did
it did you never close your eyes anymore
when i kiss
your lips
[Laughter]
see you're holding on now you don't want
to laugh out loud
i'm trying not to laugh okay that was
really good yeah
he's got my back okay mclovin has a show
bet for you darius so this is for the
danettes all four cats okay we're gonna
bet we want the patriots to have more
wins this year than the dolphins and if
the patriots do you have to host us at a
football game at south carolina
deal
well he'll host you even if that doesn't
happen you guys just said that it was
gonna be you and we're gonna send us
pictures we got so jealous
well that's a great setup
but now it's an official bet
yes
i don't know if darius wins if the
dolphins well he'll be happy if the
dolphins beat the patriots
exactly i'll take that all right yeah uh
so i'll uh maybe see you on saturday
night
i'll be looking for you man well looking
forward to it but there might be other
like bigger country stars there so i
don't know if i'll yeah
that's all right that's all right yeah
you're still doing about interesting
first yeah who's the best celebrity
singer you guys ever had
uh singer
domikowski
the former packer quarterback yes he
sang let her cry and he was saying it
the way i wrote it it was unbelievable
and but the best musician ever this was
a quick story i could tell you i get a
phone call you know i'm really good
friends with uh with coach carlisle that
who coaches the page the pacers now used
to go to the mavericks yeah he can play
piano we're playing dallas and he goes
hey man you know i know you're coming to
play but i'll get i play piano can i
play with you
and so we're like you let them do you
let people do it but you're like man you
know we do this special this thing on
like what do you want to play like let
her cry we're like oh my goodness we do
this thing on ladder crime okay we do
this piano breakdown you know okay we'll
let you play
and we get there and we start playing a
song and he starts playing piano and
everybody in the band couldn't believe
it he was unbelievable
he was unbelievable and we get to the
breakdown and he killed it and i just i
after the show i was like coach carlisle
you can play with us anytime you want he
was unbelievably great
what happens when john daly shows up and
wants to come on stage and sing
i turned the band and go y'all know
knocking on heaven's door let's do it
one two three four
the last time he sang it was at the
monday after the masters your your
charity golf tournament he got done with
the song he walked over off stage and
kissed me on the mouth
yes
no no that's not good i was like
i never want to hear this song again
john daly just sang it okay
and he walked over and he just kept
walking over and he grabbed my face and
he kissed me on the mouth and my son
goes does he do that every time he sings
this i know scott i hope not
i hope not um all right so i'll see you
this weekend thanks again and uh good
luck to your uh dolphins this weekend
all right man i'll talk to you later
okay but that's uh darius rucker he's
got a lot of country hits and uh my
masterpiece is uh latest single from him